some college teams are still fighting to
get their way into the tournament
but there's a legendary high school
program on the bubble and on and off the
court Dana Jacobson is here with the
story of Bob Hurley and his friars of
st. Anthony's
good morning Dana good morning Bob
Hurley is one of just three high school
coaches to be inducted into the Naismith
Memorial Basketball Hall of Fame after
five decades on the sidelines of st.
Anthony's in Jersey City New Jersey
Hurley's program is still at the top of
its game but the coach is racing against
the clock to save his school with an
unyielding determination striving for
perfection Bob Hurley has built the
basketball program at Saint Anthony's
high school into a perennial powerhouse
[Applause]
early has been a part of 28 state
championships in 50 years on the
sidelines he's racked up more than a
thousand victories with several
undefeated seasons a lot lately which is
good as you're getting older defeated
last year right and then in oh wait 11
and 12 so we've been pretty relevant in
the last decade a small Catholic school
in Jersey City st. Anthony's has been a
godsend to thousands of inner-city kids
but it's million-dollar debt to the
Archdiocese could force the school to
close its doors for good
at the end of the year
in hearing from the Board of Trustees
st. Anthony's wouldn't still be here
without you and the fundraising efforts
that you've led I will do whatever I can
accept the ask because if I ask
something I have to give you back twice
what I would ask so I try to paint the
best possible picture I can about the
school without wanting to ask for help
what Hurley did agree to do is let
Showtime a division of CBS follow the
team this season
highlighting the program and what it
means to its players it's a story that's
been close to me for a really long time
I grew up around the program my father
grew up and played basketball with Bob
coach with him in the 70s so his family
he is family
executive producer Brian Daly pitched
the series this past summer after
hearing about st. Anthony's dire
financial situation from his dad
the diocese had had kind of stepped in
and said we can no longer help so you
guys need to figure this out fast or
it's over and when you heard that what
did you think two things one if this is
indeed the end it's going to be a very
compelling story and it needs to be told
on the other end of that hopefully we
catch something that is a happy ending
and we're able to help them in st. in
the school what are you doing the
uncertain future hasn't caused coach
Hurley to go easy on his players you
should quit basketball and get a
part-time job what did you think when
you saw yourself I it is what it is I
look at myself and I say I need to be I
need to be a little more sensitive like
catch it so I don't know whether it's
shooting but I'm sensitive when they
need to be sensitive how I care about
the kids but when it comes time for
doing things that they should be able to
do I don't lower the bar early got his
start as an assistant coach at st.
Anthony's when he was just 19 years old
I became a probation officer as they
became the varsity coach and then
because I got involved in it stuff guy
started to tell me stories and all the
stories were back to their 12 13 14
years old and they stopped making bad
decisions and once they could of course
whatever the life potential was was gone
so Hurley brought some tough love to the
hard court over the course of time he
decided we had to enter into a contract
so now I guess we're up to about 20
things and it comes everything refrain
from the use of Alcohol Tobacco or drugs
of any kind tattoos get one after you're
finished playing clean-cut appearances
no Mohawks no facial hair cell phone at
school you're suspended from the team so
that at the end of at the end of your
four years tough love has gotten you to
a place where you can go to college we
take away some of your individualism
when you don't know what to do with it
and we let you save it for when you get
in college when you might know what to
do with it since 1992 the entire student
body at st. Anthony's has had 100%
college acceptance the doors are opening
for kids to do the same things that
we've been doing for basketball for a
very long time and it's life changing so
the kid that you know if the kid who's
first person family to go to college
gets there and realizes wow I'm going to
completely change what I thought was
gonna happen to me this year's expected
valedictorian is pearlies senior point
guard
RJ Coleman so you have to keep up your
grades or to play here a Jersey City
native Hurley coached his two sons at
Saint Anthony's Bobby Hurley won two
national championships at Duke his
younger brother Dan played at Seton Hall
both are away coaching at the collegiate
level but their father never strayed far
from home worried a probation officer
my wife was working for the Board of
Education how you going to pay for
college and when we were okay with the
two of them we said you can stand saying
ethics this is good
Perley now president of st. Anthony's
hasn't taken a salary in years so you're
giving your time already so much time
and money on top of it you know if you
could sit in my seed and then just think
back as my wife and I do regularly how
blessed we are he goes to the back spot
in horns and you know maybe financially
I could have done better how many people
have you met in your life that have a
lot of money and would be nowhere near
as happy as I am you can slip it this
guy's already going out you teach the
kids to compete every day to compete
level lower the bar pay attention to
detail all these things are related to
sports relate to life at the end of this
thing the effort will have been made to
sustain it because the kids in the
building or well worth it if you can't
save st. Anthony's will you have failed
no I
I think our athletic success over the
years has been against the odds you know
the amount of championships we've won
they success the kids have had it when
they've left here have gone on to
college
everything about it defies the odds and
if this ends and we just it just ends
Wow 50 years pretty good run the school
did suffer a setback on Wednesday they
lost in the New Jersey state tournament
with a season over now Hurley's focus
undoubtedly turns full time to raising
at least another five hundred thousand
dollars to keep st. Anthony's operating
next year the plan is to buy some time
to pay back the additional 1 million
dollar debt to the archdiocese what an
amazing legacy this school has though I
mean I love this philosophy of
everything he's woven here oh yeah woven
the school into the fabric of the
community no matter where you go and
even says nationwide April 5th will be
their meeting with the archdiocese where
they'll find out if they can raise that
five hundred thousand dollars can they
keep going what an extraordinary story
over there yeah and under percent
college acceptance rate unbelievable all
right Dana Jacobson thanks so much